Hello friends in a biological
classification we know that the
taxonomic ranks are the group of
relative organisms showing the level of
hierarchy
remembering them could be a tough task
and hence this is devika once again in
front of you with another trick to make
biologists simple all that you have to
do is to remember a simple sentence
what's that dear King please come over
for a good soup and that's all you will
remember all the hierarchies in order D
domain
P is for phylum C for class or for order
f for family G for genus and lastly as
for species hope you would find this
helpful see you soon with another trick
and facts till then stay curious and do
subscribe our Channel